let's jump over to the next story
because um the next one is whether or
not we're going to see massive riots
across the country
right yes yes or no answer will will we
see substantially worse rights this
this year oh man uh
substantially worse no i won't say
substantially worse because they were
real bad last year don't think it'll be
worse this time no i think the police
will be better prepared seems like
they've been better prepared in uh
brooklyn center do you think there will
be riots
yes all right we got this story from fox
news which i found i'm sorry i laughed
when i said it when i saw it
greg jarrett says derek chovin
prosecutors meet the burden of proof
in trial what and he opens by saying
defending the
indefensible can be futile and fatuous
endeavor
and then he talks a lot about stuff blah
blah blah at the end he says
it is never easy to reach a decision
unanimously when presented with
conflicting testimony as noted herein
jurors tend to resort to common sense
and wisdom grounded in their own life
experiences
in this case the great weight of the
evidence favors the prosecution
it has sustained the burden of proof we
had a reasonable doubt
that what derek chovan did was not only
wrong but criminal
i can't believe that's true uh based on
everything i've seen so far
and i'm curious mr lawyer if you agree
with greg jarrett that the prosecution's
prosecution has met the burden of proof
proving that uh derrick chauvin was uh
not only wrong but criminal i i don't
think they've proved causation beyond
reasonable doubt um i don't think i
thought
dr fowler's testimony i thought was very
reasonable
um there's just a lot of potential
alternate causality here
i mean the guy had a 90 blocked heart
artery he was he had 11 man
nanograms per milliliter of fentanyl
system along with methamphetamine
and i think it was what 5.6 of north
fentanyl meaning metabolization yeah
metabolized fentanyl i mean
you had the testimony about him sleeping
in the in the car it had to be roused
um he decided to fight with the officers
and have this huge adrenaline spike
that could have been a heart attack and
well so so here's here's my issue right
so let's go through the charges this guy
is saying they met the burden of proof i
don't see that we've got murder two
murder three we've got a manslaughter in
second degree
and uh assault in the third degree which
is
they're go the the murder two they're
going for is the felony murder rule
correct
so that means they're they're they're
arguing that chauvin did not want to
kill
george floyd yeah there's no there's no
none of the charges require
intent to kill that's that's the key
thing to understand right they're going
for unintentional
murder to depraved heart murder 3 which
is also unintentional
and then involuntary manslaughter so
that's all
none of that requires intent to kill so
that's why they didn't spend any time
proving it
there was a point in the trial that i
wrote several times where the defense
cross-examined the state's use of force
expert from la
and based on the continuum charts of the
continuum where shows like
passive resistance which is you know
going limp or
you know not standing up active
resistance which is fighting and then
active aggression where you're like
shooting at somebody
in the category this guy said in this
continuum
the defense expert witness i'm sorry
sorry the prosecution's expert witness
said
george floyd was actively resisting
right next to it it says
it said like electro whatever you know
force compliance or whatever which is a
taser and
nelson the defense attorney said so
chauvin could have used a taser
immediately upon encountering george
floyd actively resisting the other
officers
and the prosecution's witness said yes
and he goes and then chauvin chose a
lesser force option of restraint instead
and the expert witness for the
prosecution said yes that to me right
away
threw everything out the window it seems
like
based on that argument alone chauvin was
trying not to hurt the man
right i mean to minimize right you could
see i mean that could in and of itself
be reasonable doubt
i think this the defense is going to
have problems because the defense use of
force expert was a clown
yeah a complete clown i mean the attempt
to say that it wasn't a use of force to
hold the guy on the ground because
well it's a constraint position so
there's not even an inquiry as to
whether or not the force was excessive i
mean i thought that was in
it was indefensible it was revealed on
cross to be indefensible you basically
like retracted his
entire opinion uh within five minutes of
cross-examination so that was really bad
and i think
it's a it was a huge miss opportunity
for the defense because i think you're
right because you know
there were the defense use of force
experts plural
had conflicting testimony i mean you had
the lapd guy
saying that holding somebody in the
prone position under the circumstances
was justified use of force
and then you had the academic saying it
wasn't right uh and all you need is a
guy to get up there and say
which is it you know which is it and but
just you have your own defense expert
who says look under the totality of
these circumstances this was a justified
use of force
rather than trying to say it wasn't a
use of force at all like you just say
like
given the resistance and given the fact
that they thought he was going through
excited delirium it was reasonable for
them to hold them on the ground
uh and try and and just restrain them
and prevent it from moving and that's
what they were doing
the crazy thing to me is that they're
trying to claim that chauvin murdered
floyd
that he was the he was the cause of
death but they can't even tell us
definitively what the cause of death was
right i mean they they say that it's a
hundred percent
low you know positional asphyxia they
changed their position
initially it was that it was pressure to
the neck cutting off
oxygen to the brain and then apparently
because of one of their own experts
testifying
about how the knee had moved they
switched it up to saying it was you know
pressure
resulting in low respiratory function
yeah i mean the weakest part of so tobin
says it was both
the knee on the back and the holding him
in the prone position and then also the
knee on the side of the neck at times
um which to me honestly doesn't make
that much sense because i mean i don't
know if you've like done this but like
this isn't near your airway
right like the idea that knee on the
back of the neck would close your airway
it just doesn't make sense that's what
he said close your airway
right like it would it would lead to
your breathing expert i guess right he
was a breathing expert but
and the the defense expert said there's
there's no literature on this
like and to me that was the moment of
like yeah
i mean you're saying he choked via that
and then the positional asphyxia thing
um it's the fowler was able to suggest
pretty strongly that
the guy who like came up with the idea
and wrote about it said it really only
applies to people who are obese because
you're pressing their gut
up into their lungs it doesn't apply to
people like floyd who was
quite you know six six two thirty but
very lean how do you
how do you con what is the argument the
closing argument from the prosecution
going to be could you even predict it
i mean the closing argument is going to
be use unjustified use of force means
it's assault
so that's felon that's murder too uh the
knee on the neck is so
egregious and appalling that that means
it's murder three two um
and then he died of positional asphyxia
dr tobin said he did listen to him
and the other guy is not credible he was
paid something like that
i mean they had one of their defense
experts i think a couple of their
experts were paid as well
but sure yeah and i don't think being
paid in the circumstances
is i mean i don't think it makes you
more or less credible i mean the fact
that you're volunteering and wanting to
try and put a guy in jail is weird
i i agree yeah having this guy be like i
want to fly out here and then come and
speak so that i can you know make my
i mean the prosecution team they had the
most they had neil cat y'all
do you know i don't know if you guys
know neil cat y'all he was my former
criminal law professor he was former
acting solicitor general of the united
states
he was he was serving on the prosecution
he was like they brought him in for
motions practice right to argue
to argue some of the legal points he
would zoom in and like argue them and so
you've got eric nelson
the random criminal defense attorney are
you against neil catyal who argues more
supreme court cases every year than any
other private wow like just why
oh and the prosecution team is also
mostly private attorneys uh what
so blackwell um the the the bald black
guy
and then and then schleicher who handled
who handled a lot of the other cross
examination
both of them are like private litigators
that that keith ellison brought in to
handle the case
there's only like one state prosecutor
the the woman the woman with brown hair
she was the only prosecutor who's
actually
a prosecutor in her day job they
overcharged chauvin
yeah they should have gone with what
manslaughter i mean i think man two is
the correct
charge here but you don't even think
he'll get that i don't think he'll get
that because i think
i think at the end of the day there's
going to be a juror who says to himself
i don't know how he died yup that's
reasonable doubt but
even if even if the jar is like i think
he most
likely died because of the knee on the
neck that's still
doubt right right he could still he
still gets off in that case
like you you know and that's going to
come up that the closing's going to
focus on that i guarantee you
the the defense attorney is a smart guy
i guarantee you that defense attorney
knows he's in a lot
bit you know i guess deeper water on use
of force than he is on causation
and he's gonna drill down and be like
unless you are a hundred percent certain
that chauvin died of positional asphyxia
not guilty
yeah right
i think didn't cahill mention in
september it looked like floyd swallowed
pills
there was a tweet i pulled up from it
from from like a local journalist
yeah i mean there was there was there
were pills in the back of the squad car
with his saliva on them
the speed ball a half chewed speed ball
found in the squad car
yeah so i i i pulled this up there was a
tweet from back in september when they
were you know setting up the trial
setting up the
the case where the judge said that he it
looked like in the photos
floyd had swallowed pills do you think
the defense is going to bring up to the
jury
george floyd was seen on camera
ingesting what appeared to be drugs
he was with a man that was testified by
his own girlfriend to be their drug
dealer
they found drugs in the vehicle and he
had the drugs in his system
which as you've heard already fentanyl
depresses your respiratory system
and methamphetamine causes heart
arrhythmia
we can't be sure how george floyd died
yeah
i mean there's there's a very powerful
closing and it's it's a lot harder
to rule it out i mean they basically
have to rely on these
pieces of dr tobin testimony that said
well if you had a heart attack you would
have seen this and this and this
who gets the last word though
prosecution does right yeah but i mean
the prosecution already had its
i think yeah the prosecution gets the
last word in opening or
yeah that's powerful it is but it's
still beyond a reasonable doubt and i
think i think at the end of the day the
defense has it
um i've seen you know i think about the
robert durst case where the guy
literally
uh uh what's the word for uh
not decapitated but uh dismembered he
dismembered his neighbor
uh the dismembered body was you know
pieces of the dismembered body were
found in the
in the lake or in the in the river the
axe used to do the dismembering was
found in
in durst's car uh well um
what what was this this was uh this is a
great hbo show called the jinx which you
have to watch
oh yeah yeah yeah yeah the jinx the jinx
it's incredible
um and uh he claimed self-defense
you know um said said that the guy was
his friend
and uh you know you you know when do you
dismember someone in self-defense
so how did he get acquitted that's
that's he got he managed to give
persuade reasonable doubt that he that
the
thing that led to his he's like i didn't
murder him i did dismember him
i think it was it wasn't at the new york
post that the headline was
durst who cut up body claims
self-defense
that was the new york times that said
that wow
yeah it was that was a headline well
hold on that's something we got to
consider though
if tonight we see rioting and i think
one of these jurors lives in brooklyn
center
and the rest of the jurors still have to
commute through riots
to get to court do you think they're
going to show up on monday's sweat and
bullets knowing that if they say not
guilty that it's going to be a brick
through their window and their house on
fire
maybe i mean i could see somebody
hanging the jury because of that they're
just like not willing to go with a not
guilty verdict so i say i think
you know i think hung jury is a real
possibility here and that means they
redo the trial again later right right
it would just be a mistrial
wow um what's the difference between
murder three and
manslaughter uh murder three is what's
called depraved heart
uh murder so like that's supposed to be
really really
you know involuntary manslaughter is is
you know killing someone without intent
right generally it's that's the usual
crime like for example uh
the dante wright case where the woman
mistake mistook her taser for
a mistake her gun for a taser and shot
the guy that's an involuntary means on
her charge
so the so the one cop says she i don't
think she's actually made her statement
yet
right right fair enough but like that's
what they charge that's the first thing
they charged
but depraved murder is is things that
are like really beyond the pale
that indicate a depraved heart so you
know juggling chainsaws
juggling chainsaws and you throw someone
at somebody or something
i think i read that the classic case in
black letter law is
uh two people are playing a modified
russian roulette where they're trying
shooting
you know there's one bullet and a
revolver and they're shooting each other
and finally one of them died
and they're like okay that's not
involuntary manslaughter even if you
didn't have intent to kill right
that's so beyond the pale that's weird
there but it's not it's not supposed to
be that common third degree murder is
not supposed to be that common um
so they're claiming that that what that
he he was he like
in his mind he was like i don't want to
kill him but a man i hope he dies like
that kind of
something or like you just i don't care
that i'm putting my knee on his neck and
suffocating you know and suffocating him
even if i'm not trying to kill him i
don't care that i'm inflicting this much
pain
weird distinction and this doesn't even
matter yeah i mean it's
it's just it's there so that sometimes
things that are really beyond the pale
can get more years
the prosecution's own witness i think
more than one testified that the
the position chauvin was in was a ground
control technique that they actually
train
the brazilian jiu jitsu guy said yes
that's a ground control technique so
it's like
i'm sorry man look nobody
wants well i should say most people
don't want anyone dying right there's a
faction of murderers i suppose they
exist and depraved individuals that's
why we have murder charges
but i mean nobody wanted to see anybody
die in the dante right case in the in
the adam toledo case and george floyd
but the cop shows up deshoven was told
it was a priority one right
that means sirens rush in guy's actively
resisting
he shows up and he sees floyd resisting
and he chooses not to tase him
i'm gonna restrain him anyway i'm gonna
use a ground control technique
everyone's screaming in his face one
guy's an mma fighter
and he's being held back by someone else
that was one of the the most amazing
things to me about the case this guy was
an mma fighter testified he
put him in a blood choke and then when
nelson shows the videos like
there's the mma fighter in front of
chauvin who's what five nine 140 pounds
and someone was holding this guy back
stance the reason that chauvin felt he
was in a very
serious threatening he was a little
distracted like i would be distracted in
the circumstances how do they not
have reasonable doubt it's it's like i'm
sorry but at this point
i have like it's not it's not reasonable
doubt it's like
what's overt uh uh
disbelief you know what i mean like
right like you think you mean you just
think he's innocent
yeah i know right like that's that's
simple i love how the left
their attitude is but we saw it on video
yeah it's like
all the context the training policing
none of it matters and i can't stand how
the left is covering this like they're
they
are not preparing their audience at all
for an acquittal
like they're just they're saying that
this is trial is going swimmingly for
the prosecution
and it's like there was a day that went
really well for the prosecution when
they cross examined
yeah the use of force expert but every
every other day i would say
the prosecution has not been that great
um you know they
they had like tons and tons of witnesses
and
nelson was able to get out a lot on
cross i so
so i'm not a lawyer i don't typically
follow criminal trials
and i i thought when
the the prosecution's use of for use of
force experts were testifying
i thought it was a defense witness yeah
i was like wow this is great the defense
is really laying it out and then i was
like wait that's the prosecution's
witness
yikes he brought in a guy to claim that
chauvin was doing what he was supposed
to do
and could have done worse wow yeah i was
like
are they trying to lose or i can't
remember who it was that we were talking
to they said
there's just no case i mean it one on
the one hand it's really hard because
there's a lot of what chauvin is doing
i mean and there's this mismatch too
right like the thing that really seems
like excessive force is in particular
the knee on the neck or in the neck area
and also like holding on to him well
after he's lost his pulse that seems
like excessive force
but so much of everything that led up to
that was was policy
like i think they conceded you know
holding somebody in the prone position
for excited delirium i thought that i'm
pretty sure that was minneapolis policy
right
but but also they're like yeah but why
nine minutes because the mma guy
was screaming in his face and being held
back and chauvin was very distracted and
didn't know what was going on
because they were they thought ems was
coming and be right there and they were
just trying to like hold on
did you see the prosecution's uh uh
expert use of force witness
who said when he was asked by on cross
have you ever
held someone in a restraint until ems
arrived
yes i did yeah so it's like
yeah wow that's i mean it's just it's
just true so
yeah i own witnesses over and over and
over again that was crazy to me
and then i i was reading the crazy thing
about is i'm watching the trial
and like i said the first the first time
i i tuned i i tuned into the to the
cross-examination i thought it was the
defense's own witness and i was like oh
wow we're in the defense
wait a minute the defense hasn't started
their case yet
wow and then i start watching the
mainstream media and what do they do
they show only the highlight reel of one
fighter landing punches
they omit the defense the craziest thing
about that
i think it was slate.com right lefty
publication
where they say is the defense
floundering
and then they're i see these articles
where they're like the defense is
helpless and i'm like
when your commentary is derivative of
biased news sources and you don't double
check
you write opinions that are based in
just
yeah nobody was watching cross i
remember we were watching i think cnn
uh a couple you know a couple days ago
during um
the defense witnesses and and finally
their analysts were talking about
cross-examination
and how like they were able to ask
questions and things like that and i'm
like i realized
you guys haven't even talked about
cross-examination yet yeah you got it's
just
you've only broadcast highlights of
direct yep and you have no
and that gives you no clue about what's
actually happening in the case
these people have invested everything in
the resistance in donald trump that's
why there are still these youtubers and
there are still these news outlets that
are writing about donald trump today
it's amazing they talk about january 6th
almost every single night i watch cnn
and msnbc every night they talk about it
literally i don't know we'll watch it
with me would you say almost every
single night
almost every night i mean rachel maddow
did like 40 minutes on russia
trump russia no what 40 minutes talked
about
russia trump russia and then she talked
about
i think it was dante wright she talked
about for a little bit
or it was yeah there's like there's like
20 minutes of the riots to
russia so these these people have an
audience
of cultists that they've whipped into a
cult
over the past several years and they
know if they give them real information
that offends them their minds will
explode
so they're like okay let's see we have
this trial and the prosecution
expert witness says chovin should not
have done that that's great we'll put
that
uh for for 10 p.m or for 10 am then we
have the defense they said
actually he should not have done it but
it was part of his training let's throw
that in the garbage and then
let's this next one says chauvin was
using it because of force we'll put that
right there and then
but that's my opinion and not the facts
because he was trained to do that and
other officers do it as well let's throw
that one in the garbage
right just the highlights this is a
major part of what's stirring up riots
you have
all of these viewers watching what they
think is the facts of the trial they
turn on
cnn msnbc every single night and then
what if he gets off well what they've
been watching
is showing them to them obviously he
should have
been convicted imagine what you know
once he gets off it's like
they have more of a reason to go out and
riot imagine watching a boxing match
where they only show you you know
fighter and in the blue shorts
punching the fighter on the red shorts
over and over again you're like oh this
is brutal it's
over man this is oh geez and then all of
a sudden
they they go to call it and they raise
the arm of the guy in the red shorts
you're like but
he didn't land a single punch they'll
even be like why does that other guy's
face look so busted up yeah right
it doesn't matter if you want it right
yeah and then they
see it and it'll be cognitive they won't
even question why it looks like
literally that's how the human mind
is built or actually maybe a better way
to put it is like it's a world series
match it's you know baseball
and it's the uh i don't know i don't
know any teams give me a team we got the
white sox
indians do they play against the indie
the socks they play against the whites
no no they play
they wouldn't it would not in the world
series the world series is going to be
national americans so let's say cubs
so the cups yeah
so there's going to be a right no matter
what happens i mean it is chicago and uh
basically people are watching
and then they only see the home run
scored by the sox
and they're like wow it's it's it's they
got eight runs in
they must have won and then when it
turns out the cubs had nine they just
don't believe like you're lying
we watched the game we didn't see any of
that and they go around and destroy
everything riot smashing things and just
anger
i mean they're doing it again so the
dante wright thing we were watching on
cnn and msnbc
they always play the clip and you know
what they omit the part where he's being
placed under arrest and and then evades
and gets back into his car they cut they
cut
to begin the thing right after that
happens and while he's already back in
the car
in i think it was it was either 2015 or
16 there was a trump rally
in janesville wisconsin there was an
old man arguing with a young woman she
started screaming he touched my breast
he touched my breast he put his hand up
i didn't even touch you
then she punches him in the face and
someone pepper sprays her
mike.com added the most
insane edit i've ever seen because it
was within
like one second where he puts his hands
up then she punches them and gets pepper
sprayed
so they added like a flare a white flash
and all it did was cover up her punching
the old man
so all you see her doing is going he
touched my breast he puts his hands up
and then if the screen flashes and she's
going ah getting pepper sprayed
they literally cut out her punching a
guy in the face she was pepper sprayed
in self-defense of others yeah amazing
what goes through your mind when you're
like i'm gonna
edit this video and make this woman not
punch him why because they're like i'm
going to make so much money for them
that's true yup thanks for checking out
this clip from the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this
tim channel irl monday through friday at
8pm where you can leave
comments and super chat and we actually
will read your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you